bringing the latest technology to your
home
the swipe report on Sky News is
sponsored by Kai's PC world and canary
your watching is coming up on this with
show how do you feel behind the wheel
we've got the tech that measures road
rage keep calm and carry on I play a
game that responds to my emotions and
things get scary in our games review
welcome to swipe we're going to focus on
emotions this week kicking off on the
road you see driving can be a stressful
experience at times we all know that but
now there's a way to measure your road
rage while you're still in the car to
try and help you stay cool alex has been
trying it out different things set us
off in the driving seat whether it's
buses and cyclists I mean RV let me
through me like that
thank you very much or weaving through
traffic now researchers are measuring
how these triggers impact our emotions
what are you looking for so we're
measuring your facial expressions
through the camera we're also measuring
your sort of levels of excitement or
stress are you doing that through your
heart rate which is that device quick to
your ear but also do something called
galvanic skin response okay which is the
sensor strapped to your finger
which to put it very simply can measure
how stressed you are through how much
your sweat pores open or close this is
the world's first driving emotion test
devised to help drivers spot the causes
of road rage and respond calmly to
irritations sour sweets
please start feeding the driver sour
sweets after the beep I'm just gonna
hand you a salad sweet thank you very
much Patrick the test is designed to see
if you can keep your cool eating please
turn on the car's heating after the beat
controversially their data suggests
women are an average 12 percent angrier
than men but questions about the tests
accuracy have left some less than
convinced I think the reality is as soon
as you put a thing on your finger to
start measuring your heart rate you're
not going to be reacting the way you
normally would your heart's gonna start
racing there are cameras on you you're
gonna be thinking about the way your
your looking so I think it is a bit of a
gimmick
it's the latest move by motoring
manufacturers to try and measure our
vital signs to optimize the drive back
at base and my results are in how did I
do you did show some sort of emotional
response and some stress or
physiological arousal that's good we can
see so you started driving at about 10
minutes in this I believe is around the
time you're trying to pull out and
working any any way and roughly around
the time I would say this is probably
the ambulance so it did it did produce
like a sudden stress in you it's a real
question art all this is would you now
get in the car with me again absolutely
so is this a safety innovation or the
evolution of the backseat driver
either way while we're watching the road
we might have to get used to cars
watching us Alex Morgan sky news stay
with us still to come are we meeting the
start up trying to create a new
generation of video games controlled by
our emotions that's coming right up
after a roundup for this week's tech
news twitter is closing vine this pics
second video sharing a pit
four years ago the announcement came on
the same day the company said it would
be cutting more than 300 jobs globally
the social networking sites have been
losing money with competition from the
likes of snapchat and Instagram game has
faced a backlash after charging
customers to try PlayStation VR in store
people have criticized the retailer for
making gamers pay five pounds for a ten
minute test session with the headset the
company defended the move saying it gave
customers a chance to get a feel for VR
before they commit to buy Sweden has
banned cameras on drones the new ruling
categorizes them as surveillance devices
meaning users need a special permit
critics say it's a huge blow to the
industry and claim it could put 5,000
jobs at risk Nintendo has issued a
profit warning the Japanese games maker
says sales fell by a third this year
despite the success of Pokemon go it
says poor sales of the Wii U are partly
to blame and it's not just Nintendo
that's having a tough time Apple's
iPhone sales have fallen for a third
straight quarter that's despite the
drama surrounding its rival Samsung's
exploding Galaxy Note sevens gamers
beware you're in for a scare
we put the fear factor in our games
we've seen a lot of changes in gaming
over the years not least the effects of
virtual reality and ever more powerful
consoles but according to one British
startup there's a whole new generation
of video games on the way ones that are
controlled by our emotions rewarding
players who can stay calm under pressure
I've been to have a go at emotionally
responsive gaming champion this Jenga is
a new kind of emotionally responsive
game which basically responds to your
real-life emotions and makes them part
of the game so they just keep some klo
there we go perfect and that escapes
onto your clothing somewhere just
anywhere anyway yeah and what that's
doing is that's picking up a really high
resolution reading from your heart rate
and it's turning it into something
called heart rate variability so
basically is a really accurate measure
of how stressed or anxious or in control
you are so what this game does is
basically reward you for regularly being
able to get into that state of control
so your opponent will be getting a
series of spells and creature
so he's gonna Chuck a fireball at you in
this room and you want me to stay calm
yeah after in a moment so the more calm
I am the more weapons I get to use
exactly so you're summoning in a
strength and you're in a power and that
translates into more powers within the
game how do i summon inner strength so
what the game does is that it basically
takes you through the the best and most
immediate way of exerting control of
your emotions which is through
diaphragmatic and regulated breathing so
just copy this guy copy this guy yeah
which says about four seconds in and a
slight pause and in about five seconds
out he's deep breathing I've earned some
weapon you earned the right to basic you
earned the powers to use all of the
weapons that you got offered so that was
a really good start so he attacks you
first and then because you earn so much
strength you're gonna be able to cast
pretty much all of these cards against
your opponent now fireball them back I'm
not even sure I understand the rules of
the game but you can do very well
Wow it gradually gets me more kind of
more complicated I do feel like this
game is just teaching me to commit
violence wall to be your Karma's it's
not a good thing well I mean I it's it's
kind of controlled you know virtual
violence so have you made it to help
people to chill out and calm down or
have you made it as entertainment we've
made it as both really we've made it as
something which people find really
enjoyable which adds another element of
gameplay and also it as a kind of
ancillary benefit it means that people
get much better getting calm and focused
there are other areas of life that you
could find yourself suddenly much better
at handling you master emotions by using
a game like this whether it's preparing
for a big event a talk or an exam or
whether it's dealing with stress and
anxiety every day these kind of skills
are really relevant to thriving in
everyday life but I could just sit down
and breathe deep you couldn't I without
again it's a motivation to get good at
it for a much wider audience oh we're
back to the breathing man now you can
enjoy me your fun there for me okay here
we go
with Halloween just around the corner
we've thrown a fright into this week's
games review watch out
here's Alyssa
so it's Halloween and you can either
celebrate it by lighting a nice glowy
candle in a pumpkin sitting back with a
spiced latte and watching reruns of
Nightmare Before Christmas or you can
meet your friends in a virtual world and
scare the living daylights out of them
I'm hearing walkers hide and shriek is
gonna let you do that it's a game where
you kind of go into the school and your
job is to terrify your opponent who is
also in the school with you the catch is
that you're both invisible so if you're
wandering through this school
environment you've got to basically lay
all these traps for the other person and
sometimes receive glimpses of them
because you might see a locker door
opening by itself down the corridor but
that's actually the other person playing
opening the locker door looking for some
way to scare you it's a really cool idea
of a kind of two-person multiplayer
where we're seeing a kind of different
way I guess of doing multiplayer to what
we've seen in other Steam games
everything is really
some of the scares includes having
skeletons jump out of lockers or things
kind of come up in the screen like
really crazy scary faces or sometimes
it's as simple as you open a desk and a
load of bats fly outs there's different
scares of different levels and the more
you scare your opponent the higher your
score personally I'm probably gonna step
back with my pumpkin latte I am
absolutely terrible with jump scares
nothing says Christmas more then
standing on the coffee table Poundland
Santa hats swinging wildly as you copy
what looks like the silhouetted woman
from the iPod adverts as she twerks to
Justin Bieber nothing not even Christmas
turkey so it's kind of good then that
we've got Just Dance 2017 coming out
it's gonna give you a whole host of new
dance moves new songs and new things to
kind of dance choose one of the best
party games that there is in the new one
we've got 40 different songs you can
play alone or with friends and the basic
premise of the game is that there'll be
one or two or sometimes even three or
four figures on the screen and they'll
be dancing to a pre choreographed
routine when you think of Final Fantasy
you're probably more likely to think of
big sweeping tales of tragedy and
adventure rather than jokes about body
odor but the latter is what you're going
to find in world of Final Fantasy do you
remember it at all this land we call
grimoire the vast fields the icy ravines
but now a sinister wind rises it's a
cool little spin off to the main game
where this time you're controlling a
brother and sister as they adventure
through this world called grimoire it's
not the same world that you'll find in
Final Fantasy games but it's populated
with some of the most popular characters
from Final Fantasy like clouds and
lightning but rather than cloud and
lightning being their kind of sombre
selves that you'll see in the main game
here that kind of like chubby characters
to the very cartoonish and they don't
take themselves quite as seriously your
job is to try and kind of venture
through this world and try and regain
the memories of this brother and sister
help them to remember who they were
there's something quite fun about seeing
these kind of serious characters like
cloud and lightning transported into a
cartoonish world and there is a lot more
depth than you'd expect at first there's
this kind of mechanic quite similar to
Pokemon where you can capture creatures
from Final Fantasy and use them
alongside you which is quite a nifty
touch all in all it's a fun little game
that I definitely recommend for fans of
the series
well that's it for this week don't
forget you can watch any of our swipe
episodes on our YouTube playlist just
type in Sky News swipe and if you like
staying up to date with all the latest
tech news and have a look at the sky
news website in our technology section
we'll be back next week hope you can
join us then bye-bye bringing the latest
technology to your home
the swipe report on Sky News is
sponsored by Curry's PC world and Canary